AND TEAM LeBRON, 4-0 AS A
CAPTAIN.
WE HAVE DRAYMOND GREEN WITH US
AND WE ALSO HAVE SOMETHING ON
SOCIAL.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, DADDY.
>> I AM SO PROUD OF YOU FOR YOUR
FOURTH ALL-STAR SELECTION.
WE LOVE YOU.
>> THERE YOU GO, DRAYMOND.
HOW YOU LIKE THAT?
>> I LOVE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE ENJOYING
BEVERLEY HILLS.
>> I WOULD LOVE THAT TOO.
>> YOU GOT TWO JOBS.
YOU GETTING TWO PAYCHECKS.
YOU GOOD.
>> THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
I APPRECIATE THAT VIDEO.
I LOVE MY GIRLS.
MY BABY GIRL WASN'T ON THERE BUT
SHE IS HERE WITH ME.
IT IS GREAT.
AND LITTLE D.J. IS BACK HERE AS
WELL.
I LOVE THEM.
I THANK Y'ALL FOR THAT VIDEO.
THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
>> LET'S MOVE TO THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
WE WILL GIVE IT TO CHUCKSTER.
GET US STARTED ON THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE RESERVES.
>> START IT OUT.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
OSCAR GOES TO, FROM THE MIAMI
HEAT, JIMMY BUTLER.
>> JIMMY BUTLER, A SIX-TIME
ALL-STAR IN HIS 11th SEASON NOW.
22 POINTS A GAME, SIX REBOUNDS,
SIX ASSISTS.
HEAT 32-20, SECOND BEST RECORD
IN THE EAST.
SEVEN GAMES AT LEAST 30, FOUR
TRIPLE-DOUBLES.
MISSED SOME TIME EARLIER THIS
SEASON BUT HAS COME BACK WITH
FIRE FOR THE 32-20 HEAT.
SO JIMMY BUTLER, THE FIRST OF
THE EASTERN CONFERENCE RESERVES.
JET.
>> BACK ON ME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE SECOND
RESERVE FROM THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE, FROM THE CLEVELAND
CAVALIERS --
>> NICE.
>> DARIUS GARLAND.
>> WINSTON, YOUR SON MADE IT.
>> THIRD SEASON IN THE LEAGUE
FOR DARIUS GARLAND AND HIS FIRST
ALL-STAR SELECTION.
HE HAS GIVEN THE CAVS 20 POINTSA
I GAME, THREE REBOUNDS, EIGHT
ASSISTS AND NUMBER SEVEN IN THE
LEAGUE IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
SHOOTING 47%.
HE HAD THREE GAMES OF AT LEAST
30 AND HAD A TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
DARIUS GARLAND FOR THE 31-20
CLEVELAND CAVALIERS, A
FIRST-TIME ALL-STAR.
>> AWESOME, MAN.
>> YEAH.
>> I LOVE WHEN GUYS EARN IT AND
DON'T JUST GET THE FAN VOTE.
THIS KID DESERVES TO BE IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
>> FIRST CAVALIER SINCE LeBRON
LEFT TO BE AN ALL-STAR.
>> WOW.
THE THIRD RESERVE FROM THE EAST,
JAMES HARDEN OF THE BROOKLYN
NETS.
JAMES HARDEN IN HIS TENTH
STRAIGHT ALL-STAR GAME.
22 POINTS A NIGHT, EIGHT
REBOUNDS, TEN ASSISTS.
NUMBER TWO IN THE LEAGUE THERE.
HE HAD TROUBLESHOOTING THE BALL.
HIS LOWEST FIELD GOAL PERCENTAGE
SINCE HIS ROOKIE SEASON.
NINE GAMES IN 30 PLUS.
NINE TRIPLE-DOUBLES.
HE HAD 29-22 BROOKLYN NETS
REPRESENTED BY JAMES HARDEN AND
ALSO HAVE KEVIN DURANT AS A
STARTER.
ALL RIGHT.
SHAQ.
>> ROUND IT OUT BIG FELLA.
>> CHUCK, I AM GOING TO WHOOP
YOUR ASS.
IS THAT SOUND IT OUT GOOD
ENOUGH.
ZACH LAVINE, CHICAGO BULLS.
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
>> WELL DESERVED.
>> SECOND ALL-STAR SELECTION.
>> DEFINITELY SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
STARTER.
>> I GOT CALLED FAT WHEN I SAID
THAT LAST WEEK.
>> 25 POINT A NIGHT FOR THE
BULLS.
SHOOTING 48%.
THE BULLS AT 32-18 HAVE THE BEST
RECORD IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
>> WHICH IS AMAZING WITH ALL OF
THE INJURIES THEY HAD.
>> OKAY.
MOVE IT DOWN TO THE CHUCKSTER
AGAIN.
GOT A LITTLE SOMETHING GOING ON.
>> AIN'T GOING TO FIND HIS BODY.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENED TO
KENNY.
CHUCK WAS ON TV.
HE IS GONE.
FROM THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS, KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
>> KHRIS MIDDLETON.
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
CHAMP.
>> THIS IS HIS THIRD ALL-STAR
GAME IN HIS TENTH SEASON.
HE HAS GIVEN THE BUCKS 20 A
NIGHT, SIX REBOUNDS, FIVE
ASSISTS, 44% SHOOTING, 38% FROM
DEEP.
THE BUCKS AT 32-21, THE REIGNING
CHAMPIONS ARE NUMBER FOUR IN THE
EASTERN CONFERENCE.
SO KHRIS MIDDLETON JOINING ZACH
LAVINE, JAMES HARDEN, DARIUS
GARLAND, AND JIMMY BUTLER.
WE HAVE TWO ENVELOPES LEFT.
>> SURE YOU WANT ONE?
>> YEAH.
I AM GOING TO TAKE THE LAST ONE.
>> OKAY.
>> AND NOW FROM THE BOSTON
CELTICS, JAYSON TATUM.
>> YES, SIR.
>> FOR JAYSON TATUM, HIS THIRD
ALL-STAR SELECTION AND THIRD
STRAIGHT IN HIS FIFTH SEASON.
26 POINTS A NIGHT IS NUMBER 11
IN THE LEAGUE, EIGHT REBOUNDS,
FOUR ASSISTS.
16 GAMES OF AT LEAST 30 POINTS.
THE CELTICS PLAYING BETTER
LATELY.
THEY ARE UP TO 28-25.
THAT IS NUMBER NINE IN THE EAST.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK, CHUCK?
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING.
>> ONE LEFT?
>> ONE LEFT.
>> I AM GOING TO GO --
>> WHY DON'T WE JUST ANNOUNCE
IT.
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S JUST ANNOUNCE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOUR LAST RESERVE FROM THE
EASTERN CONFERENCE.
FROM THE TORONTO RAPTORS, FRED
VANVLEET.
>> CONGRATS.
>> WELL DESERVED.
>> OKAY.
>> YES, SIR.
WELL DESERVED.
>> THAT IS HIS FIRST ALL-STAR
GAME IN HIS SIXTH SEASON.
21 POINTS A NIGHT, FIVE
REBOUNDS, SEVEN ASSISTS.
12th IN ASSISTS, 22nd IN
SCORING, EIGHT GAMES OF AT LEAST
30 PLUS AND HAD A TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
THE RAPTORS ARE 26-23.
SO THERE ARE YOUR RESERVES IN
THE EASTERN CONFERENCE.
BUTLER, GARLAND, HARDE